the story of the man behind a diesel
engine why he'd be turning in his grave
[Music]
franco-german engineer Rudolf diesel
started by designing fridges but in 1892
he patented a revolutionary compression
ignition engine known as the diesel
engine unlike steam engines or early
petrol engines it worked by squashing
air inside a cylinder making it hot
enough to ignite the fuel and create a
powerful explosion it was a very simple
and economic system it was invented to
run on a variety of fuels including coal
dust and vegetable oils one of his early
devices was demonstrated at the 1900
World's Fair in Paris it ran on peanut
oil and won a Grand Prix his invention
was more eco-friendly and power
efficient than alternatives at the time
and farmers could literally grow their
own fuel diesel became an evangelist for
the use of vegetable oils as fuel in
1912 he said the use of vegetable oils
for engine fuels may seem insignificant
today but such oils may become in course
of time as important as petroleum and
the coal tar products of the present
time Diesel's new engine made him a
millionaire by the time he reached his
forties but his life ended tragically
in 1913 while traveling from Belgium to
England on a steamship he drowned see
there were strange circumstances
surrounding his disappearance and death
which encouraged conspiracy theories
while some people assumed he had killed
himself others thought he'd been
murdered by foreign agents there's
little evidence however and the case
remains unsolved
after Diesel's death crude oil became
more widely available and his engine was
adapted to use petrol as his only source
of fuel
this type of petrol became known as
petrol diesel or simply diesel the
diesel engine went on to revolutionize
the transport system after the first
world war
powering trains boats and buses the
first diesel lorries appeared on roads
in the 1920s and 30s the first
production diesel car in the world was a
Citroen Rosalie introduced in 1933 until
very recently half of all new cars sold
in Europe were diesel but Diesel's image
has taken a big knock with the scandal
over cheating in emissions tests there's
also more evidence and awareness about
the potential health problems diesel can
cause sales in Europe dropped 20% in
2018 some cities in the world have
banned or imposed heavy tolls on diesel
vehicles maybe we should have stuck to
Diesel's penis engine
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon